bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
le rendez vous d'actualité européenne
des chaînes parlementaires dans cette
émission direction le portugal
nouvel eldorado des riches retraités
européens le gouvernement portugais a
décidé pour mieux sortir de la crise de
les attirer en les exonérant d'impôt
suscitant l'ire de ses concitoyens mais
d'abord l'actualité
la bretagne est secoué par une crise
sans précédent motif l'écotaxe c'est la
question la semaine
depuis quelques semaines la mode est au
bonnet rouge
une majorité des années 16,175 symbole
de révolte en bretagne car depuis
quelques temps les bretons sont en
colère motif la crise que traverse le
secteur agroalimentaire et son cortège
de plans sociaux de licenciements de
fermetures d'usinés
à la clé des milliers de postes
face à cette impasse la mise en
application de la future écotaxe prévu
le 1er janvier prochain passe très mal
une taxe poids lourds dans une région
sinistrée hors de question
le ras-le-bol fiscale est en marche
depuis un mois les manifestations se
suivent et se ressemblent portiques
détruit radar arraché face à la grogne
le gouvernement plie mais ne rompt pas
la taxe sera suspendu n'est pas
supprimée alors la crise continuer ses
tirs s'étale contaminent d'autres
territoires
le bonnet rouge fait tache d'huile et
d'exécutif glisse alors peu tous sauvés
l'agroalimentaire de retour
et pour évoquer cette question de
l'agroalimentaire breton c'est jean paul
besset qui nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau merci d'être avec nous merci et
vous vous êtes donc député européen
membre du groupe des verts et membre de
la commission des affaires économiques
alors on voit ces images d'une rare
violence pour une région qui ne nous a
pas habitué à cela
quelle est votre lecture de ce conflit
ma lecture c'est qui c'est un énorme
malentendu il y à des shows france
sociale en particulier en bretagne mais
pas seulement en bretagne il y à une
inquiétude une angoisse terrible par
rapport à l'avenir et la taxe poids
lourds est prise en otage comme le bouc
émissaire en quelque sorte de toute
cette crise cette crise sociale alors
qu'est ce que l'écotaxe est une bonne
mesure flambeau elle est présente et
elle est présentée comme l'instrument de
tous les péchés et
alors que c'est un outil d'avenir
c'est un outil pour sortir justement de
l'impasse dans laquelle la bretagne et
d'autres régions sont c'est l'impasse
c'est un des outils qui peut permettre
d'aller vers un autre modèle de
développement est ce que vous comprenez
que cette espèce de ras-le-bol fiscale
telle qu'on l'appelle aujourd'hui passe
mal dans un territoire qui est déjà en
crise à du moindre en pleine mer est de
comprendre on peut comprendre la
violence de la crise
la violence des crises d'ailleurs
puisqu'elles sont sont multiformes est
telle que c'est normal que les gens
réagissent et spontanément un tout d'un
coup une taxe qui arrive on a
l'impression
on a quasiment l'impression que la taxe
poids lourds est la cause des problèmes
de la bretagne
c'est ce qu'on allait évidemment ce qui
n'est évidemment pas le cas puisqu'elle
n'existe même pas encore et on
s'aperçoit que dans les pays européens
où elle a été mis en place en autriche
en allemagne en suisse également fait
pas partie de l'union européenne
ça se passe très bien ça se passe très
bien il ya aucun problème et ça rapporte
de l'argent et ça permet de réguler le
trafic poids lourds donc c'est un
malentendu c'est un malentendu il faut
expliquer c'est sans doute de la faute
et du gouvernement et des écologistes
qui n'ont pas su faire assez de
pédagogie de loin de là c'est à nous de
reconquérir les esprits mais jamais à
cabrer c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas
été capables vous écologistes et
d'expliquer le fondement de cette taxe
incontestablement
incontestablement il faut chaque fois
quentin quand quelque chose ne va pas il
faut pas les chercher les causes à
l'extérieur il faut se regarder dans la
glace et les dire pourquoi pourquoi ça
ne marche pas ça ne marche pas dans la
conscience des gens
parce que ça paraît comme une taxe
supplémentaire un truc en plus à payer
alors que la situation est déjà déprimé
et collectivement or si le contraire
c'est un outil pour sortir de cette
dépression alors justement le problème
de cette impasse enfin entre guillemets
bretonne prend sa jeunesse dans
l'agroalimentaire enfin le problème de
l'agroalimentaire breton qui n'a pas su
se réformer à temps je voudrais qu'on
écoute ce que disait stéphane le foll
il y a quelques jours
la bretagne va bénéficier du doublement
de ses moyens sur la politique de
développement rural dans lequel il ya ce
qu'on appelle le fameux feader c'est le
lien entre l'agriculture et le
développement rural dans la perspective
de la fin des aides à l'exportation qui
est parfaitement compréhensible par tous
ceux qui vont nous écouter eh bien on
est une filière qui se construisent sans
ces êtres qui soit à la fois adapté aux
besoins et au marché auquel s'adresse et
en même temps en capacité d'être
compétitive
jean paul besset est ce qu'il fallait
maintenir les aides à l'exportation dont
bénéficiait le secteur agroalimentaire
breton notamment les exportations de
porc et surtout de poulets et de poules
et de notre point de vue bien sûr que
non ça fait des années que en
coordination avec tous les mouvements
des pays du sud des pays du tiers-monde
et pays pauvres
le nous nous battons contre ce système
des restitutions comme ça comme on
l'appelle ici avec cette mention tous
les cons exportatrices on donne de
l'argent parce que en mai le poulet
français n'est pas compétitif par
rapport au brésilien même par rapport
aux îles pourraient être il pourrait
l'être si on faisait des produits dedans
des circuits courts dans la proximité
des produits de qualité il pourrait
l'attirer à vous les poulets breton
n'est pas voulu être qualité les poulets
industriels ne sont pas des sais pas qui
les bretons c'est ce sont des couleurs
du sua c'est sur le mode de production
qu'ils soient breton ou d'ailleurs c'est
pas c'est passer par un problème y
compris brésilien de ce point de vue là
donc ce problème des subventions à
l'exportation c'est un vrai scandale
c'est un vrai scandale depuis des années
ça a permis de maintenir de 2,2 mètres
sous sous sous perfusion tout un secteur
agricole français et en faisant
s'effondrer les filières agricoles les
lectures des paysans du sud en
particulier africains qui ne pouvait pas
être concurrentiel par rapport à ses
exploits à cette manne qui arrivait sur
sur le sur leur marché à bas prix 72
millions d'euros qui ont bénéficié
essentiellement à doué à tilly sabco
donc absolument absolument
c'est alors qu'est ce que la taxe poids
lourds qui l'on connaît maintenant c'est
ça c'est cette équipe ce système
économique tournée vers l'export ce
système agroalimentaire tourner vers le
plus de production possible avec ces
ateliers d'engraissage de porc avec
cette poulailler géant avec ces choses
scandaleuses d'ailleurs par rapport aux
animaux eux-mêmes par rapport à la
qualité qui est qui et produits pour sa
tournée vers l'exportation
au bas coûts et on peut exporter à bas
coûts parce que le tarif routier et sous
tarif et parce que justement ça ne coûte
pas cher oui mais on pourrait vous
objecter que la bretagne aujourd'hui et
quand même
très mal prise en charge par le
ferroutage c'est-à-dire parle pas par le
fret qu'il n'ya pas d'autre alternative
justement la taxe poids lourds étaient
là pour avant des finances
financièrement tout ça ça va coûter cher
à la bretagne de ses lames attention à
la france devrait elle a fait ça va
particulièrement la bretagne ça devait
lui rapporter beaucoup d'argent pour
améliorer ses transports ces routes
je le ferroviaire c'était c'était un
outil formidable du point de vue
budgétaire mais du retournement
économique sur sa suspension
on est on parle bien génération c'est ce
que le gouvernement fin du mois il fuite
que ça pourrait être mise en oeuvre pour
l'été prochain est ce qu'on vit croyais
je sais pas si je dois y croire ou pas
je suis parent par par nature méfiants
parce que les choses les choses évoluent
en tout cas nous du point de vue des
économies on fera tout pour le retour de
la delà de la taxe poids lourds dans des
bonnes conditions
il était peut-être nécessaire de
suspendre d'euros dialoguer d'expliquer
expliquer expliquer toujours il faut
convaincre il faut convaincre que cette
taxe poids lourds pour la bretagne pour
l'agroalimentaire pour les paysans pour
tout le secteur agroalimentaire pour les
transports c'est une bonne chose
alors c'est une bonne chose enfin je
suis pas sûr que les bonus soient
d'accord quoi qu'il en soit est ce que
vous feriez un petit peu
l'irresponsabilité des industriels
agroalimentaire breton qui n'ont pas su
responsabilité le mot et est dure mais
mais mais c'est une c'est une incapacité
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls à imaginer
le futur à comprendre qu' il ya des
périodes dans l'histoire quelque chose a
marché et puis ça évolue et puis tout
d'un coup on se retrouve dans une
impasse ça peut pas perdurer
éternellement à coup de subventions et à
coups de méthodes de production qui sont
dépassés comment faire sortir
l'agroalimentaire breton de l'impasse
dans ce cas là l'hélico l'écotaxe la
taxe au poids lourd était une d1 des
outils un des outils pour donner plus
d'argent la bretagne pour permettre la
reconversion vers une économie de
proximité bien des circuits courts vers
vers un modèle agricole qui ne soit pas
tournée vers l'exportation tourner vers
les transports tourner vers le toujours
plus vers l'extérieur mais tourné sur
lui-même recentrer sur lui-même sur sa
sur sa propre consommation
mais pour ça il faut anticiper il ya des
transitions nécessaires et du point de
vue de la solidarité nationale
il faut organiser les transitions pour
les entreprises qui sont en difficulté
c'est pas la faute des ouvriers de ces
secteurs et des foulées pour
l'exportation de paris a terminé quasi
15000 postes supprimés pas supprimée il
faut reconvertir
il faut reconvertir et une agriculture
de qualité ça demande plus de bras ça
demande plus de travail humain c'est ce
sont pas des machines se sont pas le csa
demande plus de paysans d'aller nourrir
les bêtes au grain que de les mettre
dans des couveuses
industriels merci beaucoup en attendant
jean paul besset d'avoir été avec nous
pour évoquer cette question nous on
continue dans la partie débat et
magazines
direction le portugal lisbonne plus
particulièrement la balle et retraités
sont vent debout contre le gouvernement
qui a offert un dispositif plutôt
avantageux aux riches seigneurs aux
européens
qu'est ce que c'est une exonération
d'impôts reportage de mounir souci
habitué à voir sa population s'exiler le
portugal serait-il sur le point de
devenir une terre d'accueil
si le pays a la cote auprès des
touristes de nombreux européens songent
à y poser leurs valises notamment les
retraités
cédric et français est agent immobilier
à lisbonne depuis plusieurs années il
conseille les candidats à l'installation
j'aime recevoir un mail du frère de
celui qui était vêtu du luxembourg lui
de 8 en france et il ya ce traité va les
mêmes informations pour pouvoir
s'installer ici le temps depuis quelques
mois ses clients changent et le portugal
devient la destination pour passer ses
vieux jours on a noté une augmentation
mais exponentielle du nombre de
retraités qui souhaitent s'installer au
portugal qui font des demandes au moins
pour s'installer à lisbonne ses traits
marqués c'est vraiment très net c on a
aujourd'hui pratiquement une demande par
jour à deux demandes par jour ce qui
n'était pas le cas encore ya six mois
car depuis le début de l'année 2013 le
gouvernement propose une mesure fiscale
très attirante pour les seniors
étrangers une exonération d'impôts
pendant 10 ans pour les anciens salariés
du privé seule condition les idées la
moitié de l'année sur le territoire
jacques un ancien parisien s'est
installé à lisbonne il ya six mois
jeu de toute façon j'avais choisi de
venir m'installer au portugal et pour
pour la ville pour le climat pour la la
gentillesse et dix ans le côté
extrêmement
extrêmement accueillants de nos amis
portugais à la clé un cadre de vie
agréable et une réduction substantielle
de ses impôts je cherchais un moyen de
pouvoir minorer la charge fiscale qui
m'est imposé actuellement le portugal
accueille à bras ouverts ce type
d'exilés le pays en quête d'argent frais
compte sur eux pour sortir de la crise
dans ce cabinet d'avocats fiscalistes on
légitime cette politique ils vont
attirer des personnes d'autres pays pour
vivre et pour ils pouvaient plus pour en
même temps pour solutionner des
problèmes économiques aussi et des
recettes fiscales
c'est vrai qu'ils vont être ici en train
de vivre et ils vont payer le terreau et
à tous les jours tous les impôts en ce
qui concerne leur patrimoine et ça sera
ce sera une façon aussi d'augmenter les
recettes les revenus fiscale du
gouvernement
depuis trois ans le gouvernement
portugais fait face à une grogne sociale
sans précédent des coupes budgétaires
successives ont fait descendre des
milliers de personnes dans la rue dans
les cortèges
de plus en plus de temps grise comme
cette ancienne bibliothécaire qui a
perdu 400 euros de pension en deux ans
alors les cadeaux fiscaux accordés aux
étrangers sont dures à avaler
depuis un an elle milite dans une
association de défense des retraités
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 5000 les
européens ne sont pas nos ennemis nous
devons nous unir
mais il faut que les gens comprennent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas choisir l'endroit
où ils vivent juste en fonction des
avantages fiscaux qu'ils offrent
l'europe doit être tel que jean monnet
la fonde et de l'atlantique à l'oural
nous devons avoir les mêmes conditions
de vie
des conditions de vie de plus en plus
difficile pour la population portugaise
dans ce centre de santé de la banlieue
de lisbonne
les journées sont rythmées par les
flashs d'information à la une encore et
toujours la crise économique
au moment où je vous parle la réunion
entre les ministres portugais et les
commissaires européens vient de se
terminer
la journée va se poursuivre par un
déjeuner de travail vous voulez du sucre
1 dites le moi et je vous en apporte ici
ses pensionnaires ont vécu l'essor
économique du portugal depuis son entrée
dans l'union européenne
aujourd'hui marche arrière comme tous
ils subissent de plein fouet les
réductions budgétaires
g 87 ans et avec ce nouveau gouvernement
aujourd'hui j'ai perdu la gratuité de
certains soi je ne suis plus indemnisés
pour isabelle à la tête du centre les
plans d'austérité successifs pèse sur
les budgets et sur la qualité d'accueil
bdf de manitou se fout de nous n'avons
pas assez d'argent pour acheter la
nourriture les médicaments et on sent
bien que l'on doit réduire tous les
services que l'on propose on peut plus
en faire autant c'est très dur pour les
gens de vivre avec des retraites qui
n'arrêtent pas de baisser 4 4
et les coupes vont se poursuivre le
prochain budget table sur 4 milliards
d'économies et les retraités vont de
nouveau en pâtir le gouvernement a déjà
prévu de baisser de 10% les pensions des
fonctionnaires et pour parler avec nous
de cette question des retraités qui vont
s'exiler sous le soleil de lisbonne
c'est rui tavares couleurs souvent sur
ce plateau bonjour vous êtes député vert
portugais et jean paul goze à sion ne
vous présente plus député européen
membre du groupe du parti populaire
européen alors à la vision de ce
reportage pardon mais est ce que ça vous
choque pas un petit peu qu'on a changé
comme sept pays sous prétexte que le
régime fiscal vous est plus ou moins
avantageux on est effaré premièrement
félicitations pour le reportage écoutez
je suis content qu'ils aient acquis qui
a aidé des européens qui vont lisbonne
c'est ma ville et je crois que c'est une
ville qui a dérouté et pas que pour les
retraités pour les chercheurs pour les
artistes pour lui pour les touristes
mais comme m'a dit ma compatriote qui
vous avez interviewé je ne veux pas
qu'il vienne à cause d avantage fiscal
je veux qu'ils viennent à à cause de
l'insécurité de climat de la culture de
la ville de la beauté du pays comme on
va aussi comme je suis allé étudier en
france ou dans d'autres pays d'europe
le problème c'est que l'europe n'a pas
mis sa maison un ordre en termes de
fiscalité il n'y a pas une union fiscale
en même temps que vous parler du sujet
de ces reportages que j'avoue au
portugal n'est pas très connu au
portugal on parle de deux choses les
entreprises portugaises qui s'en vont en
hollande pour payer leurs impôts en
hollande
les ventes plus grandes entreprises
portugaises paye 30 milliards d'euros
tous les ânes héros ses délires
transfert 30 milliards d'euros tous les
années 90 ce que veut dire que si c'est
la moitié du prêt qu'après on à l'europe
à faire portugal via l'afrique a donc
voté déjà 5 à csm
ces prêts dont on pas en train de nous
expliquer que là on essaye de faire
venir des retraités étrangères mais
venir concerne les entreprises sachant
que le portugal perd aussi l'équivalent
de dix mille personnes par mois qui vont
s'exiler en angola etc
si on ne perdrait pas notre argent de
nos entreprises qui s'en vont vers vous
n'auriez pas fait revenir les retraités
et vous et nous n'aurions pas fait venir
les prêts des autres pays européens qui
sont payés par les contribuables
français allemand espagnol 4,6 alors
pourquoi jean paul gauzès vous qui êtes
à la commission qui se charge de ce type
de problème pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas remis de l'ordre dans la
maison
c'est à dire oui tu as fait il ya deux
deux questions différentes ya le fait
que des retraités aille s'installer au
portugal pour bénéficier du climat de la
chaleur humaine du portugal moi je
trouve ça ça prouve que l'europe existe
ou non nous retraités en france il
allait souvent sur le sud est plutôt que
vers nord du pays pour la retraite donc
finalement ça prouve que l'espace
européen liberté de circulation des
personnes et des biens est réalisé et
que finalement on peut se le peuvent se
créer je vais revenir aux aurès ensuite
veut peu secret des des compensations
déséquilibres macroéconomiques en
exploitant dans les pays les richesses
qu'on a
le tourisme c'est une richesse
l'hébergement des personnes âgées ce
peut être une richesse ça donne du
travail de l'activité donc ça c'est un
modèle positif et très bien si les
jambes est ce que pour autant l'aspect
le choix uniquement pour des raisons
fiscales je dirais c'est un peu dommage
c'est dommage parce que la vie n'est pas
faite que de fiscalité deuxièmement se
pose le problème que souligne man au
collègue l'a juste titre c'est celui de
l'harmonisation fiscale entre pays
opèrent pour ma part je suis
farouchement pour l'harmonisation
fiscale
pardon elle n'arrive pas pourquoi parce
que la fiscalité relève des décisions
souveraines des états prise à
l'unanimité et donc sur tout souci
d'harmonisation il a toujours deux trois
états du bloc et les efforts qui sont
faits actuellement
n'aboutissent pas je vous donne un
exemple très concret on veut essayer de
trouver une base commune pour l'impôt
sur les sociétés j'ai pas bientôt comme
une base où ça soit calculé de la même
manière et qu'on puisqu'elle est comparé
éviter des fuites que si j'ai signé mon
oncologue d'un essor eh bien on n'y
arrive pas pourquoi il ya des 28 pays de
l'europe technique des raisons
techniques pour dire y'a pas les
agrégats comptable c'est idiot mais on
n'a pas cette volonté et regarder
lorsqu'il s'agit de bouger de la tva les
difficultés parce que il suffit qu'un
seul pays bloquent pour que ça n'avance
pas sans parler du taux d'imposition sur
les sociétés qui peut être à 12% en
irlande et c'est pourquoi on veut qu'ils
une base commune
c'est justement pour qu'il y ait une
comparabilité si vous avez 12 % sur une
base très petit ça fait pas beaucoup
d'impôts si vous avez 30 % sur une base
beaucoup d'impôts l inverse
est ce que vous êtes d'accord monsieur
tavares sur ce dispositif maintenant
qu'il faut sortir en fait le portugal de
la crise à l'heure où il ya un nouveau
plan d'austérité qui a été voté qui va
aussi grevé le budget des retraités de
10% semble-t-il est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure d'essayer de relancer cette
demande intérieure en attirant les
retraités européens au moins je ne suis
pas pour la compétition vers vers le bas
en europe c'est à dire tout le monde s
exemple sur les entreprises
tout le monde baisse les impôts aussi
sur ceux pour la phase qui fiscalité du
patrimoine
je crois que ça on n'aura pas de fin
avec oui c'est en puits sans fond il ya
encore pire au portugal au portugal
maintenant on a un système de visas doré
qui attire parler deux généraux angolais
oligarques russes et serra qui peuvent
s'acheter une maison au portugal ce qui
s'appelle le golden visa si c'est en
plus de 2 millions
dans ils ont accès à un visa spécifique
qui investissent et ils achètent au
portugal golden visa qui leur donne un
petit peu dans une situation où on ferme
les portes aux immigrés qui ne sont pas
riches qui ne seront pas des généraux
des tyrans des oligarques russes etc
moi je trouve parfaitement scandaleux
qu'on ouvre les portes à ce genre de
fortune acquise en plus dans des
situations la plupart très très suspect
alors spect justement là-dessus il ya
une femme qu'on l'a vu dans le reportage
qui souhaitait vous poser une question à
vous députés européens au likoud
pensez vous réellement qu'avec la
politique actuelle qui engendre la
pauvreté et l'inégalité dans notre pays
nous sommes sur la bonne voie vers la
concrétisation du projet européen ou si
au contraire nous sommes en train de le
condamner
donc messieurs la question est claire
est ce que par ce biais là par ce manque
de courage politique de la part des
européens on n'est pas en train de
clouer un petit peu l'europe
je ne prends pas que manque de courage
politique il y avait des situations d'un
certain pays qui était très difficile et
il était nécessaire de redresser les
finances publiques
donc moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui
pensent qu en étant très de deux tués et
le projet européen et les populations
nous pose simplement la question j'y
répondrai pas mais je pose la question
que se serait-il passé si les pays qui
sont en difficulté aujourd'hui qui sont
sous programmes comme on dit dans le
jargon technique n'avait bénéficié
d'aucune aide s'ils avaient été livrés à
eux mêmes ne suis pas sûr que le
résultat serait certes mais alors on
prend le problème de la grèce et je me
tourne vers monsieur tavares aussi même
le fmi au mois de juin dernier a pointé
le fait qu'ils avaient un petit peu
était trop loin sur l'austérité donc ça
c'est autre chose c'est la capacité
technique des gens qui donnent des avis
de ce point de vue moi j'ai plusieurs
fois exprimé des jugements sévères sur
l'est sur la compétence des experts qui
lance des idées sans être sûr qu'elles
sont bonnes mais c'est deux choses
différentes que de laisser les pays
tranquille tout seul se débrouiller ou
leur apporter de la solidarité
alors est-ce que la solidarité
européenne pour vous a été la bonne si
elle part avec ma compatriote et pas
pour mon collègue je crois que il faut
changer sinon je crois que le projet
européen encourent des risques énormes
ce qui se passe au portugal ce convoi du
côté de la crise
ça nous aide à faire les idées claires
on voit ça ne va pas marcher
les pays de l'ue rappelle à sa
solidarité mais les conditions qui
viennent avec cette seule sur la vérité
sont si terribles qu'on est en train de
perdre notre jeunesse qui émigrent vers
le brésil l'angola
c'est là où on a investi le plus pour
avoir un bon fait par un guépard moi
quitte le territoire
tous les ans j'ai nié les architectes
les journalistes les publicitaires tout
le monde s'en va
sont les genres
dans lesquels on avait des positivement
aux espoirs propos pour le futur vous
allez former manque c'est je crois que
il faut refaire le projet européen sur
des bases démocratiques
il faut faire une vraie démocratie
européenne non je dis une démocratie
européenne qu'elle soit fédéral ont
passé c'est pas le problème mais si la
majorité des 500 millions de citoyens
européens veulent une âme en
harmonisation fiscale moi je ne veux pas
qu'elle soit vt au conseil parce que le
luxembourg l'avaient c'est ça la
démocratie
sinon on va dans un trench vous êtes
d'accord je suis d'accord sur la
démocratie bien évidemment la démocratie
n'a porte à porte et valeurs les valeurs
économiques est le problème si je
regarde dans l'histoire
les pays qui ont aujourd'hui des
difficultés lors qu'ils étaient seuls ça
entraînait aussi les migrations
je pense que s'il ya en france au
luxembourg autant de portugais c'est
bien de résultats de la situation du
portugal avant qu'il n'entre dans l'euro
mais c'est un drôle de salade à redon
pardon mais les chiffres vont nous
contredire parce que figurez vous qu'il
ya plus de départs aujourd'hui que sous
la dictature de salazar par mois si
aujourd'hui les mobilités beaucoup plus
grande c'est aussi celle euros s'il n'y
avait pas la mobilité européenne ne
pouvait pas parti qui avait pas la crise
peut-être que ça se traduirait comme ça
mais bon ça c'est dans une période
normale
la mobilité est une chose oui et elle
est très mauvaise pour le portugal elle
ne compte dans un pays qui n'est pas
soutenable passe ça va être encore pire
dans dix ans si on n'a que les âges et
les retraités et les gens qui ne sont
pas capables de deux d'être dans un
marché global
de travail on va être un pays
insoutenable et c'est ça le problème
donc je crois qu'il faut surpasser cette
économie entre ce qui était au temps de
salazar bien sûr personne veut revenir à
cette année et est-ce qu'on a maintenant
il faut avoir un autre projet européen
je crois qu'il faut faire dans le sud de
l'europe
ce que le président roosevelt a fait
avec la tennessee valley authority c'est
à dire et des six pays là avec un projet
de l'union a lieu dans le new deal c'est
pour moi c'est pour toute l'europe
mais après aussi monsieur vous souhaitez
il a fondé une agence fédérale dans le
camp américain pour le redressement
économique des états qui n'était pas
électrifiée à l'époque qui perdaient
beaucoup de gens et c'est avec des
projets scientifiques en énergie solaire
part je suis d'accord avec vous mais ça
ça veut dire en réalité plus l'europe
n'est pas destruction de l'europe et par
repli sur soi c'est au contraire une
robe plus élargie avec eux l'espèce de
fédéralisme à la carte sur les aspects
de développement économique ce n'est que
pas sûr à une meilleure coopération
économique européenne qu'on pourra
obtenir
l'objectif que vous vous que vous
poursuivez ce n'est pas en se refermant
les uns sur les autres
c'est pour ça qu'il est importante aux
élections européennes ce sont les partis
qui sont en quête d'un projet européen
et qu'ils puissent avoir la majorité au
parlement
si je peux faire une autre vous voyez
bien je sais que cet encaste c'est une
citoyenne portugaise mais dans un moment
où on pourrait être en prendre se
plaindre de l'europe elle est préoccupée
avec le projet européen
c'est nous qui vivons la tragédie mais
en même temps on est préoccupés parce
que le projet européen comme ça il n'ira
pas ce qu'on voit à l'intention si on
même cette route là donc je suis
d'accord avec monsieur vous et c'est pas
en se repliant chaque pays sur soi même
qu'on va sortir de cette crise mais il
ya si vous voulez des espèces du encore
plus d'europe
il ya celles qui les gouvernements offre
et à celle des citoyens peuvent créer et
je suis dès la deuxième est bien écouter
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
monsieur d'avoir cédé parmi nous pour
discuter de ça on reparlera du golden
visa bientôt pourquoi pas aller faire un
reportage là dessus nous c'est la fin de
cette émission vous retrouverez la
semaine prochaine m
dire à ma place à bruxelles d'ici là
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
hu